le château et du 15e mais dès la dèche à
l'époque de charles de 5 les comptes
royaux de montre que le monarque
s'approvisionnait en vain à gien il ya
toujours eu des gens qui contre vents et
marées ont tenu à faire de la vigne dans
la région et on est arrivé jusqu'à la
dernière guerre comme cela est un petit
lot pleine ligne droite à gauche ou
d'ailleurs les poux pas gentil s'ils
étaient moins et du maintien de la vigne
localement et le maintien d'un certain
renom si le roi charles 50 12 118 a fait
entrer les vins du giennois la tour de
france c'est à la famille sont pas que
ce terroir doit une grande partie de son
histoire moderne
le grand père rené est notamment à
l'origine du classement encore qu avec
ses 5 ans c'est mon père qui la prennent
l'appellation il y avait dans la région
et 20 de mauvaise qualité des vins de
bonne qualité c'était pour faire
ressortir les vins de bonne qualité et
ce combat pour la qualité s'est
poursuivie pendant quarante-quatre
années avant que l'inao ne décide enfin
d'octroyer qu'une appellation d'origine
contrôlée à des coteaux du giennois un
terroir dont les soucis
quelques uns se répartissent de part et
d'autre des frontières du loiret et de
la nièvre twitte des ravins harmonieux
c'est c'est grâce et fruité on a une
belle carte sistance en bouche ce n'est
pas ça fait des vins de restructurer il
ya l'appellation contrôlée et les autres
c'est un bon amalgame entre les ventes à
dun pays vdqs tout est globale et je
crois que là c'est un plus
épandre géré plus pourquoi est formel
sasp façon ça se passera pas dans
l'immédiat mais il y aura quand même un
plus
précision importante pour l'instant
cette aoc n'est qu'officieuse elle
deviendra officielle dans trois mois à
la signature du décret par le premier
ministre